a woman who shot her husband ten times
was charged with murder but Colleen
mckernon claims she acted in
self-defense on New Year's Eve in 2014
her defense team hired forensic animator
Scott Roeder to prove its case he
created a visual representation of what
happened the night of the crime Tracy
Smith has been covering the case in a
preview of tomorrow's 48 hours she has
an inside look at rotors work I walked
out into the hallway and I had the gun
at my side he said where do you think
you're going and I said him I'm leaving
I'm going and he started to walk towards
me and I raised the gun and then it was
over it was so quick and he was on the
ground and I was so pulling the trigger
my name is Scott Roeder I'm an evidence
specialist we've got a dead man and
we've got a woman whose life is hanging
the balance
she's the only eyewitness to this
situation Scott Roeder is not a lawyer
not a detective and not a forensic
scientist his specialty using evidence
to create visual presentations of a
crime what was your purpose in firing
that first shot to stop Rob I thought my
life is in danger I was just I believed
that Colleen mckernon is a cold-blooded
murderer prosecutor Jennifer Dave the
evidence showed that she shot him when
he was trying to leave was it
self-defense or was it murder that's I
mean that's a big question of the day
right Colleen has been charged with
Cleveland defense attorney
Ian Friedman has hired Roeder and his
company to help convince a jury that his
client had only one choice kill or be
killed there's not gonna be any dispute
as to who the shooter was he's not gonna
be in to dispute to what the weapon was
this particular item is a Glock model 26
some people were immediately making a
judgment for this is a battered woman
my daughter is innocent she's innocent a
murder and
some other people were immediately
making a judgement cold-blooded killer I
think she's a monster for what she's
committed people want rushed to an
opinion they want to rush to the story
before the evidence even has been
analyzed I stick to the physical and the
forensic evidence it's just terrible
nightmare what I want the jury to see is
that she had no choice that evening if
she were to protect herself she had no
choice but to do what she did Ian
basically asks you to recreate what
happened that night
yes that's gonna be a key piece of
evidence there this isn't about emotion
was shot eight another entrance to the
left back if I get the opportunity to
explain that to the jury I think they'll
understand you know it's that first shot
is gonna be an upward trajectory so I
think that's probably the position he
was in do you determine guilt or
innocence absolutely not why not well
that's not my job that's what the jury
does and Tracy Smith is with us now from
Los Angeles Tracey good morning good
morning how vital is this forensic
animation to the defense's case it can
be very important I mean think about it
being able to show people what you think
happened instead of just telling them
what happened can be very powerful and
that's why 48-hours hired Scott Roeder
as a consultant to take us behind the
scenes and see how he builds these
animations and helps build a case do
juries typically believe it Tracy what
they see that's the thing it's very
controversial and they're not always
allowed because even though these are
usually based on theory a lot of juries
take them as fact and in this case Scott
Roeder says that this is the most
probable thing that happened but still
it is just one version it's just his
theory Tracy Smith thanks you can see
Tracy's full report the evidence room on
a special two-hour edition of 48 hours
it airs Saturday night at 9:00 8:00
central right here on CBS